[Music]
heaven I'm concerned you went to the
doctor
this weekend is everything okay no it's
not okay okay you want to have about
yeah let me just tell you really quickly
what happened this is how I said if I
was on a baseball team by the way or a
toy what happened was I tore my bicep
muscle a couple years ago in this arm
yes I remember that yeah playing
basketball not professionally and and
and then last Friday I tore this muscle
this one I had repaired a couple years
ago and now I tore this one lifting a
couch and and I haven't had surgery for
a long time and I went to the hospital
and they prep you they tell you what's
gonna happen and the guy said would you
mind walking to the operating room and
I've never heard of this before but I
guess you know what would the economy -
cutting corners here and there you know
and you walk to the emergency operator
yeah yeah not no gurney yeah walking and
but I told the guy said that's all the
help I'm giving I'm not gonna be handing
tools and things like that and I get to
the operating room I push open the door
and it's freezing in there they keep it
really cold because in case you don't
make it they don't want your stinking up
the room funny now that quickly that you
start to stink oh all right I don't know
what you're in do you could stink when
you're alive
that is true even half the night is true
I'm sorry I besides I
so it's cold in there so I think Barack
Ono talk about the hospital surgery
operating room yeah it's cold and I see
the operating table and the it's all lit
up and they added wings on to it you
know cuz they're doing my arm so look
like a crucifix and that usually never
ends well from what I've read can I
climb up on the table and you know it's
so surreal because you're doing all this
by yourself
yeah and they give you that Michael
Jackson medicine and boom you're out
like that that is the actual that's the
drug they use yeah Wow yeah and then you
wake up and then it's all done you're
ready to rehearse are you ready to
perform yeah yeah and so I had to be in
Philadelphia like three days later and
this was a little more involved and I
thought you know I'm like taking
painkillers and it's in a sling and I
called the surgeon I said it's okay to
fly you know the altitude and stuff but
low pressure
yeah and he said to me he goes you know
what there's a good chance of a slight
chance he said of a blood clot but no
more than the plane crashing those are
the same percentages he said you should
get up walk up and down the aisle like
every 15 minutes and that's a long
flight from LA to Philadelphia that's
like a five-hour flight 77 were the
walking yeah but he just wanted you to
keep moving yeah the blood flowing
you know so I did that and I didn't know
if I was doing that to keep the plane
from crashing or from getting a blood
clot yeah I mean I didn't know what the
doctor knew right he just told you to do
it you're doing yeah and people even
thought I was a terrorist or they
thought yes Kevin we saw you when you
came on the plane
[Laughter]